this corner of bc
is called lake country and for good
reason
the perfect place for a quiet paddle
it's where burt and arlene westervelt
set out on the afternoon of june
26 2016. it was calm
clear and warm
but the trip ended in tragedy the
following day
police pulled arlene's lifeless body
from the lake
to arlene's mother gene hennig and her
sisters wendy and debbie
the loss is just as painful now five
years later
the biggest heartbreak anybody will ever
have is to lose a child
you can't sleep you can't eat
you're just missing a part of yourself
when one of us had birthdays and her
sisters or myself
and we'd celebrate that
she was just such a joy to our family
the 56 year old nurse traveled the world
in search of adventure
she had an infectious laugh loved hiking
and being on the water
it was always looking forward to the
next the next adventure around the
corner and
i just miss her so much
[Music]
on the surface arlene's death appeared
to be an accidental drowning
at least that's what local rcmp thought
at first
it's a tragic accident that possibly
could have been avoided you know when we
feel for the victim and the families and
everybody involved
but what really happened on the lake
that day is still
bitterly disputed when arlene's husband
burnt phone with the news of her death
her sisters were immediately suspicious
as soon as i heard that i just screamed
i literally screamed i said mom
this is not an accident i said he's done
something to her
i didn't even have to ask i knew
instantly that
that he killed her i just screamed it
out he killed her he killed her i know
he killed her
i knew it
[Music]
why do you think they would say that
i don't know i you'd have to ask them i
think it's a hatred you know they
you think it's a he they hate me
so it's as simple as that really while
the hennig family has screamed murder
for nearly five years
bert westervelt has said nothing
publicly until now
from outside the home he and darlene
once shared bert broke his silence to
tell
his side of this story arlene and i had
ups and downs but
when it came down to it there's nobody
i'd rather travel with than arlene
there's nobody i'd rather golf with in
arlene there's nobody i'd rather hike
with in arlene
there's nobody i'd rather bike with than
arlene
and this is mr mrs bert westerville
burch and arlene were together for 34
years
but behind idyllic scenes like this one
the hennig family says
their marriage seemed to be on the rocks
my last visit with her which was about
two or three weeks before she died
i sensed there was tension
she and bert would talk in private and
she'd come back with tears in her eyes
jean would not have known that would be
the last time
she'd see her daughter alive there was
just something strange about that last
hug and she was crying and i was crying
and her body was trembling and i said
honey it's going to be all right so then
the next third time there were contact
was
from bert to say she had drowned
the family believes arlene wanted a
divorce but bert says he never had
any inkling things were that bad
were you aware that she was that upset
[Music]
no no no i wasn't
in the days after arlene's death the
hennig family says they made repeated
calls to rcmp in the corner
they wanted a more thorough
investigation and an
autopsy to be sure of how she died the
first conversation i had with the
coroner
i begged him and pleaded with him to do
an autopsy
and he said there wasn't going to be an
autopsy
despite the family's concerns arlene's
body was embalmed
and her funeral was held eight days
after that ill-fated canoe trap
the story could have ended there if not
for a phone call from a divorce lawyer
that's the moment that changed
everything that is when
her divorce lawyer contacted
rcmp and told him that she was his
client
we don't know what the lawyer revealed
to police because attorney-client
privilege continues even after
death but we do know that call turned
the case
upside down rcmp quickly took back
custody of the body and started a murder
investigation
and even people who had not suspected
bird at first
began to change their minds
this is a location where they found
arlene's body
dawn hennig is arlene's uncle he was on
the lakeshore
with bert the day police found her body
she was just like a daughter to me
she was i was very close to her unlike
other members of arlene's family dawn
didn't immediately suspect burt of
killing his wife
they were on friendly terms but as news
of the rcmp investigation began to leak
out
his opinion changed then when i found
out the rcmp were involved
i suspected something wasn't right dawn
keeps a daily diary
and one entry in particular sticks out
our lead stopped by for a few minutes
last night
was crying i asked her what was wrong
and she
didn't want to talk about it and
finally she said to me i guess all
married couples fight
and that was the last time i saw her
dawn says there are things about
arlene's death that don't make sense
like the fact she wasn't wearing a life
jacket at the time of the alleged
accident she always wore her life jacket
and and she
she was a pretty good swimmer he had no
problem and
she was in really good physical shape
[Music]
why wasn't she wearing a life jacket
yeah i can't
we're getting to that point now where i
can't
my lawyer has said i can't talk about it
burt's lawyer would not let him comment
on any of the specific events in the
canoe that led to arlene's death
because the case is still technically
before the court
but dawn talked about it including the
first story he heard from bert
he told me that he thinks arlene reached
for a bottle of water and
just he said i leaned over to counteract
the way the
canoe was leaning and over it flipped
the family says
burt initially claimed the canoe tipped
and arlene surfaced
then he dove to get the life jackets but
when he came back up
she was nowhere to be seen did
bert's story about what happened with
arlene's death change over time
yes it did don says burt later claimed
that when he and arlene surfaced after
the canoe capsized
there was some kind of struggle in the
water he said
she went under and i guess he
grabbed her arm or something and she
punched him i find that
very odd why do you think his story
changed
well
because i think he was lying
your story shouldn't change if you tell
the truth
what do you think happened to arlene i
think she was murdered
do you think bart murdered her yeah
i do eventually
the police and crown prosecutors also
believed burt had killed arlene
in 2019 they charged him with
second-degree murder
but in a stunning reversal the crown
announced it was staying the charge last
summer
offering no explanation why that
effectively brought the case to a halt
just two months before the preliminary
inquiry was supposed to start
we haven't seen any justice we need
answers
outraged and demanding answers yet again
arlene's family held a rally at the
kelowna courthouse
and hired lawyer anthony oliver to press
their case
so in this case we had a preliminary
inquiry that was scheduled for multiple
weeks
with dozens of witnesses and for
whatever reason the crown's office
blew the whole thing up
on june 27 2016 arlene westervelt's body
was pulled from the waters of okanagan
lake
almost immediately the investigation
into her death started to go wrong
and anthony oliver the lawyer
representing arlene's family says
it all started with a high-ranking
member of the rcmp
named brian gately now what occurred
in those early days is still unclear
and it certainly does have something to
do
with brian gately who was then an
inspector with the rcmp
in the days after orleans death but
before a murder investigation was
launched
burt westervelt asked gately to use rcmp
resources to unlock his wife's cell
phone
there were pictures there of our our
last
dinner at the point and i really want
adults
now this wasn't a formal request burke
claims the two men were casual
acquaintances
gately took arlene's phone and got
another officer to unlock it
even though as a veteran mountie he
should have known that could be a
serious breach of rcmp conduct
that was a huge risk to his career
to unlock that phone why do you think he
would do that for a casual friend
i don't know i don't know and you know
had i known that i may not have asked
him either
arlene's family believes the two men
were actually friends
not mere acquaintances her sister debbie
claims burt wanted the phone unlocked
not for the pictures
but to see and potentially wipe clean
any secrets it might hold
he wanted to get into the phone and
maybe
read past texas and conversations and
see who she'd been communicating with
either way
gately's actions were controversial
global news obtained
this internal rcmp code of conduct
letter
it alleges he used a phone hacking tool
called celebrite
for personal or unauthorized reasons
gately refused our request for an
interview but global news did obtain a
letter he sent to arlene's sister debbie
in february
in it he claims he only had the phone
unlocked after investigators assured him
arlene's death was being treated as an
accident
but there's a problem with that too
because there's another allegation in
that code of conduct letter
the gately weighed into arlene's death
investigation with his personal opinion
a potential conflict of interest if he
knew
a party in the matter that being bert
westerfeld
he should have checked himself out
immediately and he didn't
even though gately was not assigned to
arlene's case
oliver believes he convinced
investigators to treat it as an accident
in those crucial early days
gately claims he wasn't involved in the
case and that his actions did not in any
way
compromise the investigation or the
prosecution
but those code of conduct allegations
were never resolved because gately
retired
arlene's family has since filed a
complaint against the rcmp
for allowing gately to resign before the
code of conduct investigation
was finished mike cavilla is a retired
homicide detective in calgary
the family's lawyer asked him to provide
an independent assessment of the case
was this accidental
was this non-accidental and inflicted is
this a homicide
none of those decisions can be made
within the first
hours of the events
unfolding cavilla was surprised at how
quickly investigators jumped to the
conclusion that arlene's death was not
suspicious
particularly given that there were no
independent witnesses nearby
any water death needs to be treated
as suspicious and should go to a full
autopsy
immediately but that didn't happen
it wasn't until arlene's divorce lawyer
stepped forward that mounties opened a
murder investigation
an autopsy was carried out 10 days after
her death
and by then the body had already been
embalmed
it was a mistake that could have
resulted in vital evidence being lost
the coroner's report was finally
released four and a half years after
arlene's death
and it raised a chilling possibility the
autopsy found hemorrhages on the strap
muscles of arlene's neck
and both eyes hemorrhages in the eyes
can occur and hemorrhages in the neck
can occur from strangulation
dr john butt is a retired forensic
pathologist
although the coroner's report found no
marks on arlene's neck or
damaged to the bone under the chin he
believes strangulation
is still a possibility he's urging
authorities to take another look
at the evidence i think that an
independent review in this case
would be important i definitely do the
report also claims the embalming didn't
interfere with the forensic examination
of arlene's neck
dr butt disagrees he says incisions made
in the neck during the embalming process
could be a big problem for crown
prosecutors at
trial the incision can of course
mask other evidence that might have been
present or
create evidence that may be misleading
and it's my opinion that was one of the
reasons why the charge
against the accused was stayed
while the embalming may cast doubt on
the cause of the neck hemorrhages
the doctor hasn't heard an explanation
for the eye hemorrhages
well the hemorrhages in the eyes are not
common with drowning
that's for certain bert westervelt says
betty noble the coroner on scene when
arlene's body was found
told him she saw no evidence of any
injuries
so i asked her for signs of physical
trauma and betty noble said no
it was emphatically no none
the report confirms no injuries were
found at first
it wasn't until the autopsy was done
later that the hemorrhages to arlene's
neck and eyes were discovered
the family's telling us that they were
trying to get an autopsy done in the
days following arlene's death
but that you wouldn't allow it why were
you opposed to it
i wasn't crazy about it because i just
felt arlene had been through
enough you know and
i just wanted i really just wanted to
leave her be
in hindsight do you wish that you'd
requested an autopsy at the time i
yeah again yeah
probably yeah ultimately
the coroner couldn't rule out the
possibility that arlene died from an
underlying heart condition drowning or
strangulation
her cause of death was found to be
undetermined
burt westervelt maintains that there was
never a solid case against him
you saw the case that was built against
you
what stood out to you and that why would
they charge you
that's a good question
that's a good question i don't i don't
know
i still to this day don't know how it
got this far
so your story changed in the days that
followed arlene's death do you
understand why that might raise
suspicion
yes i do and you know i apparently
that's
a large part as to the reason why i was
arrested
did you kill your wife
[Music]
sorry did you kill your wife no god no
[Music]
arlene died in 2016 and you were
arrested
three years later what's this time been
like for you
it's been hell yeah
yeah you know but it's not just on me
it's
my friends my friends family my family
it's been hell for a lot of people
that might be the only point where burt
and his in-laws agree
we are left with very very large hole in
our hearts
our family is so broken we miss her
so much and we want to know
why she died allegations of interference
from mounty brian gately
and questions about the competence of
the rcmp and bc coroner service
may have compromised the crown's ability
to prosecute bert westervelt for
murdering his wife
there could still be justice the
government has the option to order a
pure review of the evidence by an
independent forensic pathologist
but the clock is ticking the crown has
until july 14
to restart the murder case against bert
westervelt
after five long years arlene's family
just wants their day in court
my sister was a beautiful person
whose life mattered and she deserves
justice and make no mistake we're not
going away
and we are not going to give up our
fight